singapur es modesto en tamaño pero
cuenta con una historia de gran éxito
económico uno de los países más ricos
del mundo pero es también uno de los más
amenazados android
gates bajo los objetivos de emisiones
podemos llegar a 90 centímetros y hay
una probabilidad muy baja de que debido
a que no entendemos las capas de hielo
de la antártida y calderón understand
antártica hay chips
tal vez se eleve en realidad a
aproximadamente 17 metros es mi altura
permite tener ese trayecto
esto es hay 2000
detrás de la sonrisa hay una
preocupación muy real por el futuro las
lluvias torrenciales en marea alta
unidas al aumento del nivel del mar han
hecho que la ciudad de estado se ve
afectada por devastadoras inundaciones
repentinas en los últimos años como
muestra esta animación the straits times
el nivel de las aguas podría subir 5
metros en el peor de los casos y
sumergir parte de los emblemáticos
muelles de singapur
es muy aterrador y da mucho miedo sin
duda este es uno de los lugares más
hermosos y también lo llamo hogar
crea una especie de pánico al mismo
tiempo crea mucha responsabilidad de
nosotros sobre cómo contribuimos a
evitar que este desastre llegue en el
futuro
pero singapur se defiende ha destinado
al menos 70 mil millones de euros para
hacer frente al cambio climático en los
próximos 50 a 100 años
formas de potasio para nosotros la
protección del litoral es una amenaza
existencial porque el 30 por ciento del
territorio en singapur no está a más de
5 metros sobre el nivel del mar casi un
tercio de la isla está amenazada por las
inundaciones
stallergenes parte de la solución pasa
por los diques vertical los diques de
contención y las compuertas de marea los
proyectos de recuperación de tierras
deben estar al menos cuatro metros por
encima del nivel medio del mar uno más
que antes los costes son elevados pero
singapur está decidida a convertirse en
pionera en la lucha contra la crisis
climática